the santis seemly calling for military
in intervention in Mexico let's roll
that and talk about
it as commander-in-chief I'm going to
use the US military to go after the
Mexican drug cartels they are killing
our people and the stories that I've see
in Florida we had an infant 18 months
parents rented an Airbnb and apparently
the people that had rented it before
were using drugs the infant was crawling
the toddler was crawling on the carpet
and ingested a fenol residue Y and died
are we just going to sit here and let
this happen this Carnage happen in our
country I am not going to do that so I
guarantee you on day one this border is
going to be a day one issue for me as
president we're going to declare it a
national merch yes we'll build the wall
we'll do remain in Mexico but those
Mexican drug cartels are going to be
treated like the foreign terrorist
organizations that they
are so is that a threat to invade Mexico
yeah like is it a declaration of war on
day one right like what's the legal
mechanism here yeah I mean I I think
Terror you you can imagine a situation
and and Mike Pence has had sort of more
reality based things to say about this
you could imagine a situation where you
have some sort of cooperation with the
Mexican Government that involves
deploying US military Assets in Mexico
with their permission and maybe you
could even pressure them in certain ways
into doing that but I I don't I don't
think it's at all clear that you
necessarily would succeed at that Amo is
you know is very much a nationalist and
I think is unlikely to be keen on the
idea of the US military attacking
cartels in inside Mexico and if you do
that without the Mexican government's
permission you you have invaded Mexico
it's like it's it's this really it's
this really hawkish bizarre idea that
could have all sorts of negative
unintended effects and it's just sort of
being thrown out there like it's a thing
like oh just like send the military um
and also like you can't you can't you'd
have to send troops if you wanted to do
this sort of thing I mean you can't
because I mean part of the problem with
the fentanyl trade is because fentanyl
is physically so small the quantity of
it that you need and because it's
synthesized artificially you can't just
like identify sites from the sky and
drop chemicals on them or bomb them or
that sort of thing it if you were truly
to have an effective operation like this
you would have to have a US military
presence in Mexico which would be a huge
policy change and if they're really
threatening to do that without the
without Mexico's permission that's
literally a threat to invade which just
seems crazy yeah and the more moderate
Nikki Haley position is just spend send
Special Operations there so it would be
sort of I guess like off the books CIA
operation or something like that um I
mean the the underlying issues here are
that uh we've got imig we've got our
immigration problems and then the drug
war and from my perspective the the
inflow of fentanyl into the country has
been a direct result of uh drug
prohibition uh
fenel has exist existed as
a uh Med medication and an anesthetic uh
in hospitals but the reason that it's
spilled onto the streets is because we
went from an opioid epidemic to a heroin
problem to now a fentanyl problem and I
think that the approach that you know
that that disc the discussion around
decriminalization harm reduction is of
course completely off the table for the
GOP but there there's also the question
of immigration which is uh you know
brought up uh over and over again um uh
on on that stage and for the amount of
times that Ronald Reagan was invoked
there was not a discussion of the fact
that the Reagan Republicans were a much
more welcoming party I mean Reagan at
the time you know offered an amnesty and
also basically was talking about a you
know a highway connecting Canada Mexico
and uh and the US like we're all you
know we're gonna have a new North
American Alliance um so that's is
obviously in far in the rear view now
but it's it it's got to be part of the
solution any serious solution to any of
these problems is uh
actually allow figuring out a way to
meet the demand of the people who want
to come and live and work here
peacefully Liz I I think uh there's also
an interesting component of this which
is very difficult to argue against
because I think it effectively tugs at
people's heartstrings but like the
anecdote that DeSantis cites about the
18-month-old baby who was crawling on
the flo of an Airbnb and touched
Fentanyl and ingested fentanyl in some
way and died as a result of this I mean
I don't know if you guys saw the daycare
the Bronx daycare what which was um this
was a story I think basically last week
where a two-year-old in New York City
died of uh I guess ingesting fentanyl in
the daycare despite having passed all of
its City inspections was actually being
used as a drug front and so now the city
is going after the people who were
running the daycare and and running the
drug front as well um but it's it's
interesting right because these stories
capture people's imaginations it's kind
of a little bit of a throwback to Milk
Carton Kids and we see this moral Panic
surrounding kids kids and razor blades
kids and Fentanyl kids and you know
whatever they might be able to access
and a I I I need to like sort of
independently do my own research and
actually verify that this anecdote
exists because just because somebody
said it on a debate stage does not mean
it is actually grounded in fact and two
like I think it's actually probably
better to bring the discussion closer to
reality we're like yes maybe every once
in a while there's an anomalous absurd
absurdly terrifying story uh like the
Bronx daycare or like this 18-month old
in this Airbnb but fundamentally we
don't really have a country where like
millions of children are ingesting
Fentanyl and dying each year like let's
be very clear about what the problem is
there is an opioid crisis but I think it
would actually be better to focus the
conversation on the median opioid user
and addict um and how to get them the
treatment that they need not these
outlier cases well but I mean the the
problem I mean these these cases are not
the typical fental problem but we're you
know we're having on the order of a
100,000 drug overdose tests a year in
the country it's and it's massively
higher than it used to be and it's you
know it's it's a legitimately extremely
hard policy problem I think a much
harder policy problem than than the
immigration issue which I think we know
what the trade-offs are and what the
solutions would be the I mean the reason
we ended up with this fenel problem as
as you described Zach is we went through
this period where the uh prescribing uh
guidelines for opioids were were much
too LAX and this seems to have been
largely an honest mistake there was a
sense in medicine that b basically you
know lots of people have chronic pain
and this was a safe way to treat chronic
pain and it was a huge mistake and it
created this large number of people with
opioid addictions and then you had that
progression in the market through heroin
and then fentanyl but I think you know
one lesson to take from that is if you
had an even if you had an even more
permissive legal opioid policy where it
was not just that we were going to go
back to writing a lot more prescriptions
but that we were going to you know get
rid of prohibition allow people just go
out and buy perco set if they wanted you
would still have a tremendous number of
of addicts and overdose deaths you you
wouldn't have two-year-olds stumbling
upon a block of fentanyl in the back of
a in the back of a daycare because it
would be a legal Market but the legal
Market would be a source of enormous
problems in the country and so it's you
know that it's not like marijuana where
you can just you know look at the the
cost and the benefits and say you know
prohibition was ridiculous and we're
better off with with permitting this you
know you you end up with enormous social
costs regardless of which policy you
choose and I think that's part of why
you end up getting this Fantastical like
let's invade Mexico because if there was
a a simp clearer thing to do about it
that's what they'd be proposing to do
which is not to say that I think the
Mexico thing is going to work it's just
people people get into these Realms when
they lack a good answer yeah I I agree
that there's no uh there's no perfect
solution um and that opioids are
certainly a much more damaging drug when
abused than something like cannabis um
the problem is that shift it you know
cracking down on the opioids after the
over for prescription happened then made
basically what it led to is a lot of
people turning to heroin and then once
that demand for heroin went up then oh
look it's cheap it's even more efficient
to just make this in a lab in China or
wherever and then sneak it over the
border and so I think that you know
there could be a more sophisticated
conversation about tradeoffs and
accepting that these that there are
going to be social ills but perhaps
there are less
damaging uh interventions than uh kind
of the simplistic let's just crack down
on it and see you know what pops up next
uh Liz I interrupted you regardless the
type of conversation that you guys are
modeling which acknowledges some
externalities and unintended
consequences that arise from different
policies and Trace the evolution of how
we got into this mess to me that's a
much more interesting way to do debate
and so I really really wish and I know
this will never really happen in US
politics but I wish we could move away
from like 18-month-old baby stumbled
across a little bit of fenel and died
and it's like the super outlier moral
panicky type case and toward the types
of things that you guys are talking
about which I think are both extremely
valid ways of approaching this I'm sorry
but like if we actually want serious
policymaking and serious people in the
white house we should have the
expectation that that's where the
conversation happens as opposed to
whatever we saw on the stage
last night hey thanks for watching that
conversation with Josh Barrow about the
recent GOP debate you can watch the full
conversation right here or another clip
over here